in the lobby of Ramsey solutions will
and Bianca are with us hey guys how are
you hi doing great Dave welcome welcome
where you from just south of Houston oh
cool and here to do your debt-free
scream we are yes sir welcome to
Nashville how much debt have you guys
paid off we have paid off a total of
forty five thousand dollars forty five
thousand and eight dollars very good and
how long did that take 15 months good
job and your range of income during that
time we started at 88 and we finished at
103 excellent very cool what do you two
do for a living I am a maintenance
supervisor okay
I do engineering document control okay
perfect fun fun what kind of debt was
the forty five thousand oh boy credit
card credit cards a lot of stupid tax
vehicles a couple vehicles motorcycle I
think some more stupid stuff in there
too somewhere okay and then some stupid
stuff okay yeah student loan uh hate
that when we first got married no you
had everything else so you are kind to
normal be bopping along but no money
right and what happened fifteen months
ago that got you on this plan well we
heard about your plan a long long time
years ago and we knew what we should
have been doing we even tried it at one
time and we won't really commit it but
uh we had some friends coming to my life
Dana and Beth and they were a living
example of what we should have been
doing mm-hm and it was kind of a wake-up
call because they were so in control of
their finances and they you know they
would something would come and it'd be a
bump in the road from them they'd be
like you know what okay I got my
emergency fund I'm not worried about it
like who are you yeah what I would have
been freaking out normal what just
happened yeah that's pretty cool okay so
they're having a really nice example put
up right in front of you made you get
serious absolutely and then what did you
do once you decide to get serious well
we can go down yeah
we finally sat down and you're like you
know I guess we're gonna have to do a
budget whatever that is
and once we started doing that we
realized you know where money was flying
away and we didn't we had more money
than we thought we did and we started
saying well we don't really need that
let's sell that get rid of that now that
they coach you this couple or did you go
through Financial Peace University or
get the Total Money Makeover book how'd
you know to do the debt snowball well
the truth yeah tell me the truth pretty
much we we're avid listeners to your
show uh-huh and we basically get your
book from you know nine months of
listening to the show and I Heart Radio
every day okay that's fair required that
you buy anything how did you know what
to do yeah so just from listening to the
show yes excellent there are the
real-world expenses and yeah and what
you were telling them say okay what we
can claim we can use that we can use
that so you know you know the baby steps
and you know that snowball all right
very good good
all right and so you just and we're
gonna do a budget what's that yeah yeah
well it kind of took a while for us we
had our loosely done budget and there
was still that you know that flyaway
money and yeah I think when I had a
mental breakdown one day and he didn't
know what was happening I was blubbering
crying something and a spreadsheet came
out of it which we had every dollar
available to us
it's just I don't know I'm kind of a
control freak yep and we're both control
freaks really mm-hmm and so before doing
the budgeting and stuff it was him in
charge and I just kind of let it go and
I'd get upset about something but not
tell him and it kind of put that little
wedge there mmm but after my mental
breakdown and we kind of worked out
together a spreadsheet together it
really it took that away and made us
stronger she definitely had to make me
sit down and do a dollar-for-dollar
because I'm you know we had a loose
budget we're like okay well we know we
had to pay that we were suddenly no
longer paying things late but we still
were okay yeah when he left over for
dead yeah so schwa why Mona she made us
buckle down and I finally agreed and
then it just took off from there very
good okay very cool that's important
what was the hardest thing to sell that
you sold
the thing that kind of made it tear I
don't know we were just ready to get rid
of everything we did when we got the
ghazal insist you know in intensity and
we just said you know okay we don't need
that we sold our couches we wound up
sitting on lawn chairs in front of our
TV in the living room had one picture of
at least when one of the chairs yeah so
we had that in our living room and then
I had a beautiful 180 gallon saltwater
aquarium that I dumped money into and it
was just a dream and I was like well
don't really need it I want a bigger one
anyway so Finding Nemo got a new home
you have a fish that brought in serious
money oh no no I just had a lot of nice
ones that I started out small and was
watching him grow she's scared to buy
fish they're afraid they might be sick
they don't want to bring the sickness to
their tank or something really very cool
all right this is awesome you guys how
does it feel now that you're dead free
relieving this whole trip up here is
paid for we saved up and it's there's no
worries we can spend it we have it we
saved up for it edited for it so you're
wearing the leather jackets did you
write up the motorcycle up here we flew
up here you flew this morning but we've
rented a Harley for the next seven days
we're gonna ride around the whole state
of Tennessee in Kentucky that's good
good for you guys way to go this is
awesome well awesome stuff all right
we'll and Bianca we're gonna give you a
copy of Chris Hogan's number-one
best-selling book retire inspired cuz
that's the next step it'll be signed by
him now you actually have one of our
books that's pretty cool so but that's
the next step is you you got this part
of your story done the next chapter is
to continue to build wealth and live and
give like no one else
so very proud of you guys very well done
very well done all right we'll and
Bianca Houston Texas $45,000 paid off in
15 months making 88 to 103 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
where to go you guys you know and and
you get on a Harley and you ride all
over Tennessee in Kentucky it's up gonna
be a beautiful beautiful ride that's
living like no one else man people dream
their whole lives of doing stuff like
that and now you're doing it it's
completely paid for as a reward for
hitting your goal and reminding you what
smart looks like and starting to be
grownups way to go you guys
very very well done hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
common